Let's go next to a Thomas from Canada. Thomas
from Canada. What's going on today? We've
heard from Thomas before.
Hi. Hi David. Is this am I in my online?
You're on. You're on the right now, literally.
Okay great. So I um, I called again cause
I was wondering, I was wondering what you
thought and I, and I, and I've noticed that
you've brought this up and I say this respectfully
cause I, I really do enjoy your show. This
notion of the American dream. So from a Canadian
perspective, it seems bizarre. Oh, do you
know what I mean? No, I don't tell me. So
encounter, well, we don't have an equivalent
to the Canadian dream and not really. We do
and we don't. And we also don't like, so while
we are, I think a proud people, we also don't,
and I've also noticed you and I say this respectfully,
you know, talk about this notion of what our
founding fathers thought. Well, in Canada
we don't say, well, you know, our founding
fathers, the founding members that can have
thought this, we look at them at like, we,
we, we look at them as people who died about
a century ago in what they thought is irrelevant.
Right. Okay. Okay, good. So this gives us
some good materials. So yes, number one, Canada
seems to have a much healthier and realistic
relationship with the founders and the documents
that the founders put together rather than
as almost quasi religious documents. Um, but
more just as like, this is the best thing.
Certain people who were flawed came up with
at the time based on what they knew then.
And things have changed. The world has changed
and we need to take that into consideration.
So it seems that there's a much healthier
relationship there in general than we have
in the U S with so-called constitutional fetishists.
What would you like questions? Would you agree
that there's almost an [inaudible] and I say
this out of respect to you know, cause I cause
you, you, you come off as an academic, someone
who knows what he's talking about and I, and
I respect that compared to some other channels.
Um, and I, and I wonder like, why is there
almost a PIR severance? I'm this notion that,
well, our founding fathers was against this.
Who cares that your founding? No, no. How
do I say that? Better yet? Is it relevant?
And 2019 if your founding fathers were racists,
who cares? They're, they've been dead for
two centuries, right? Isn't it so much more
now? But yeah, I worry, these are talking
points that say Democrats and Republicans
and God knows everyone else in the middle
and left and right. Hey,
well, yeah, no, you're completely right. These
were talking points that are meant to defend
a particular political view and conservatism
in general wants to keep things the way they
were for the sake of keeping them the way
they were. I mean, these are of course generalizations,
but the idea of of, of progress is to change
things for the better based on what we know
now and learning from the lessons of history.
Conservatism wants to keep things the way
they were in some kind of nostalgic pre, previous
period. And so the constitutional fetishism
serves a particular political ideology. And
in the same way, by the way, Thomas, you mentioned
the American dream at the beginning of the
show, the idea of the, of the American dream
at the beginning of the call, the idea of
the American dream also supports a particular
set of ideas and actions, which prop up, uh,
industry and the status quo, the American
dream, which includes for example, home ownership
and having two cars, even if you can't afford
them, which funds big corporations and interest
bearing loan, you know, you, you, you, so
it all has be interpreted in that context.
I think.
Well, and, and, and my question, I now have
even noticed that some of the young Turks
and I, and I think they are and, and even
other channels, David theater, I believe.
And I am my, my, my question is why is it
like the American dream is obviously a false
God obviously. I mean it's there to, to support
capitalistic, um, socioeconomic ideas. Why,
I mean, I don't, it's, it's, if we all could
become millionaires, then there'll be no meaning
and being a millionaire any longer. I mean,
logically still have. If everyone was given
the same amount of money today, well then
we'd have a new system than certain, you know,
it's a very, like from a Canadian perspective,
I say this out of respect, when I hear this
notion the founding fathers constantly brought
up with gun laws, for instance.
Yes,
it's bizarre from a Canadian perspective,
and I say this respectfully, so it is a bizarre,
weird notion to see, well, yes, two centuries
ago, what th th I can't imagine they thought
AK 47 would be a thing one day. Yeah.
Completely agree with you, Thomas. Absolutely.
A point well made in one. One I've made in
the past. A pleasure to hear from you and
I'm going to try to get to some other colors.
Okay.
A pleasure. A pleasure to talk to you again.
All right. Very good. Thomas from Canada,
Thomas from Canada.